Welcome back everyone it's charlie.
this is my house of the Dragon season2
top 10 WTF predictions video just like I used
to do every season for the main Game of Thrones
series they've already explained some of their
big plans for the future of the show and how
they're adapting the story and I'll be doing
house the dragon videos during the off season
just like I used to do for the main Series so
be sure to subscribe to get everything careful
for spoilers from everything from season one if
you haven't watched the show yet but starting
with number one the question on everyone's
mind like biggest question when is House of
the Dragon season 2 episode 1 going to Premiere so
here's the thing there have been Reliable Reports
they won't actually start filming season two on
location until almost March 2023 it takes over
a year to turn a season around nowadays because
of all the post-production and special effects
that they have to do for all the big dragons and
everything else so it won't take quite as long
as it took season one to film because there
were a bunch of extra delays during season
one but the other big thing is the Emmys there
are all these rules about when episodes have
to air Emmy's always a big thing for the Game
of Thrones series they won so many of them HBO
loves Emmy Awards based on the new rules that
they have the entire run of season 2 episodes
like season 2 episode 10 will have to finish
before the Emmys cut off date at the end of
May or the entire show won't be able to start
till either June or later in the year none of
the season 2 episodes can overlap between May
and June so like the entire season has to finish
before the end of May or it will all start after
may I think HBO would love to go back to airing
the show in the spring like it used to for all
the old seasons of Game of Thrones but because
it takes so long for them to film Seasons now
they probably won't finish till a little bit
later meaning they would probably hold the show
till like July in order for the show to air in
the spring it would have to start on March 26th so
set your clock by that either it'll start March 26
or it'll start in like July or around this same
time next year the season one aired number two
house the dragon the dance of the dragons like
the main event that the whole show is supposed
to be covering right now will be Four Seasons
long George RR Martin revealed this recently
so it's pretty relaxed liable but also they're
turning the show into more of an anthology show
Ryan Condall the showrunner said that one of the
other shows that they referenced when they were
in The Writer's room was the crown which is like
an anthology type of series which jumps between
different versions of the actors as they get
older through time but also they plan on taking
it one step further and using the show to cover
other major time periods in the Targaryen history
like they'll jump to the past and do aegon the
Conqueror in the conquest of the Seven Kingdoms
or they'll jump forward do the blackfy rebellions
or even later do Tales of Duncan egg you get the
idea in fact the showrunner Ryan Condell said that
he was actually developing a Tales of Duncan egg
show that was completely different for HBO before
George R Martin found him and hired him on to do
this house the dragon series they still plan on
calling the show House of the Dragon because it's
still about the Targaryen family just said during
a different time period so when we get to season
five that'll be like the different time period
whether we go to the pass into aegon's conquest
or the future and do some other event and that's
how you get 10 to 12 Seasons or whatever of house
the dragon it's just them using different actors
during different time periods which is also how
they get around the problem of having to pay the
actors like a million dollars per episode because
that's what happens when shows run for like more
than seven to ten Seasons by the end of the main
Game of Thrones series all the major actors like
the biggest ones were earning crazy money per
episode number three how's the Dragon season 2
episode 1 will probably begin pretty soon after
the events of season 1 episode 10 like the next
day because as rhaenyra said to Otto Hightower
the red keep the greens would have their answer
on the morrow they ended with that reaction shot
of rhaenyra turning around all quite all pissed
off learning about luceris's death so obviously
their answer on the mara will be very different
from what her answer might have been before that
the answer will be their retaliation for the
death of luceris like they will respond in kind
with actions not words and their retaliation will
probably be a combination of at least two major
events like one big scale Massive Attack like a
traditional declaration of war where Daemon pays
off his earlier reference where he said he was
going to take harrenhal like he said they needed
to gain control of that and the riverlands as well
as paying off the alliance with Grover Tully the
current lord of House Tully that they kind of
joked about a little bit because it's kind of
a Sesame Street reference inside Game of Thrones
there's also a Kermit Tully that's around during
this period of the timeline too George R Martin
Big Jim Hansen fan either way them controlling
this area of Westeros is critical during the
dance of the Dragons because it allows them to
box in the greens in King's Landing in the crown
lands here they already control pretty much the
entire Eastern Seaboard of Westeros at this point
number four the more traditional big battle at the
beginning of season two like I said the burning
of harrenhal Daemon taking harrenhal meant to be
a big parallel for aegon the conkers conquest of
the Seven Kingdoms during the conquest harrenhal
was like the first major castle that he took it
was the Second Battle like it wasn't the first
engagement the first battle was actually in
Gold Town against the Aaron's Army after they
made landfall at what became King's Landing in
the Blackwater Rush that's why it was called
King's Landing because it's where aegon landed his
army the curse of harrenhal that they referenced
during season one actually started right after
aegon burned the castle with blur in the black
dread that's the reason why it looks so melty
because he burned it with valerian's dragon fire
previously it was the biggest castle in the
history of Westeros by far it took Harrenhal
over 40 years to build in the day the day that he
finished it was the same day that aegon burned it
how's that for bad luck that's why the Specter
of bad luck always follows harrenhal throughout
the years really good example of the curse of
Herron Hall in present day during the main Game
of Thrones series is during season two Jack
and Hagar goes around killing a whole bunch
of people mysteriously even though it was Arya
that was naming people for him the latest one we
saw in the show was Harwin strong and his father
burning in harrenhal so Daemon burning harrenhal
with vermouth or the other dragons would be like
the burning of harrenhal 3.0 and you remember now
Lord foot Kink larous strong now holds the castle
now the curse of harrenhal falls on him so expect
something really crazy really bad to happen to him
eventually eventually him getting his comeuppance
but number five Lara strong will probably be
the new little finger of the show that kind
of positioned him that way during season one too
and as such he will probably have a similar Arc to
Littlefinger like he'll survive till much later
in the run of the show so even though you have
this giant curse of Harrenhal they're strong like
Littlefinger will probably survive through all the
major battles the next few seasons till near the
end continuing Littlefinger style to influence
events and do increasingly messed up stuff if
you thought the feet stuff was weird during
season one you have no idea some of the messed
up stuff he's going to get up to the next few
seasons But ultimately that's just going to make
the payoff of his death that much more satisfying
when it does eventually happen much later but
much more satisfying I think than the way that
they paid off littlefinger's death during Game
of Thrones number six the other major WTF moment
where the blacks retaliate against the greens in
and around House of the Dragon season 2 episode 1
will probably be blood and cheese remember giving
the greens the answer on the morrow one part of
that is the traditional declaration of war with
the burning of harrenhal 3.0 the second major one
will probably be Daemon's own personal retaliation
using viseria to hire blood and cheese to kill a
child for a child an eye for an eye as payment
for luceris's death is aemond said to lucerus a
dead is owed but this time it'll be Daemon going
at the greens revenge killing one of the Green's
children in retaliation so remember a big part of
the dance of the Dragons is going to be rhaenyra
and alicent trying to avoid atrocities like this
as much fighting as possible and everyone around
them on both sides doing the exact opposite trying
to burn the realm to the ground the funny thing
the showrunners have said about Daemon though is
that like oh you know he doesn't want to burn the
entire realm he just wants to burn all the greens
and put all their heads on pie likes and in doing
that a bunch of the realm will burn the whole
idea is that neither alicent nor rhaenyra can
totally control what each of the people on their
sides can do even though it seems like they have
a lot of authority they're meant to be like the
most powerless people within their camps like
Daemon will do whatever Daemon wants to do Otto
Hightower and aemond are gonna both do whatever
they want to do as well as aegon II who is now
King and probably isn't going to spend a whole
lot of time listening to what his mother says
like the second coming of Joffrey even though
technically he comes before him in the timeline
remember Cersei could not control Joffrey it'll
probably be a similar situation with aegon II
and alicent this is one of the big ideas with
alicent and rhaenyra throughout the entire Dance
of the Dragons they want it to feel like no matter
how much alicent wins no matter how much ranera
wins both of them always wind up losing ultimately
like during season one it seems like alicent wins
everything that she wants except she ultimately
loses because Lord feet now has all this power
over her you have demon choking at rhaenyra even
though she's just put on jahiris's Crown she's
just become the black queen you think she'd be
the most powerful person in the room but no that's
actually Daemon I don't want to get into too many
spoilers for the blood and cheese stuff but if
you've read the books you know kind of what's
going on eye for an eye child for a child one of
the greens will die tragically probably in episode
one maybe episode two we'll see number seven we'll
see the rest of the dragons that Daemon mentioned
in episode 10 starting with Vermithor who they
already teased Daemon isn't going to change his
dragon from caraxes to vermithor war or anything
like that he was just summoning vermathor in the
song he was singing to it was a Valyrian lullaby
he was trying to coax Vermithor out when they
zoom the camera in on their eyeballs on the
reflections you could see his hand reaching
out to touch his snout Vermithor will probably be
ridden by one of the other dragons he's probably
Hugh Hammer who's a Targaryen bastard born on
Dragonstone he's a normal soldier working in
their army currently the reason you didn't see
him in season one is because they only Elevate
him to a more important position of dragon rider
was the actual dance begins and they need all the
dragon seeds all the dragon Riders they can find
for all the riderless dragons Vermihor breathing
all that flame to like extended flame breathing
sequence probably also foreshadowing for Daemon
taking him to harrenhal with caraxes to burn
the castle because Vermithor's the biggest
dragon in Westeros next to vegar right now so
he's a huge asset metaphorically and literally
for them Vermithor is a male dragon who used to be
ridden by King jaehaerys until his death he's just
been rightless on Dragonstone ever since then
number eight the other dragons are Vermithor's
mate Silverwing she was the dragon written by
King jaehaerys' wife alysanne who's also been
riderless on Dragonstone since alysanne died they
lost arrax when vhagar killed lucerys so they're
down one Dragon right now but will also probably
see taraxi's baby Joffrey's newest dragon that
they reference but remember baby Joffrey still
very small even though he's not technically a
baby anymore teraxis would be even smaller than
air ax and arax was like the smallest dragon
that we've seen so far so I don't think Joffrey is
going to be doing a whole bunch of fighting during
season two we'll see baela's Dragon Moondancer
and will probably see at least some if not all
of the wild dragons there are three of them it's
sheepstealer she's eventually written by Nettles
then there's Cannibal and gray ghost there are
a couple dragons that we saw during season one
already that will come back during season two
like seasmoke is a good example laenor velaryon's
dragon lots of theories about lanor secretly
coming back pretending to be a velaryon bastard
just under a different identity like no no I'm
not laenor I'm a totally different person maybe
that'll happen towards the end of the dance the
dragons there are other dragons that Daemon didn't
mention that he and rhaenyra's children aegon and
viserys eventually ride but they're still very
very small babies right now so they probably won't
claim dragons for a long time maybe we'll see them
in the final season if they cover the later events
of the show in the aftermath of the actual Dance
of the Dragons number nine sort of connected to
that idea the other major Revelation that the
showrunner and George RR Martin revealed if you
didn't realize it before that there won't be any
more major time jumps on the show during the dance
of the dragons for the most part the rest of the
dance of dragons however many more episodes that
runs will be the current actors that you see now
right now all the major children like jacaerys on
the way up to aegon II who's technically like the
oldest of that generation are meant to be between
the ages of like 17 and their early 20s by the
end of the dance of the Dragons they'll only
be like a couple years older in number 10 the
big WTF Cliffhanger at the end of season 2 will
probably be either the reveal of all the dragon
Seas like in season 2 episode 10 Daemon will roll
out all the dragon Seas riding all their dragons
preparing for like the next major conflict like
let's prepare to burn them all or small chance
they'll end season 2 episode 10 with rhaenyra
sacking King's Landing in a big parallel to
Daenerys sacking King's Landing at the end of the
main Game of Thrones series like season 2 episode
10 will literally end with a very similar moment
to the end of Game of Thrones season 8 episode
6 except this time this time rhaenyra will enter
the iron throne room and actually sit on the iron
throne and they'll cut to the credits it's not
like somebody's gonna bum rush her from behind and
stick her in the back before she sits on the Iron
Throne she'll sit on it they'll cut to credits and
then we'll pick up in season 3 episode 1 with the
greens retaliation for them sacking King's Landing
because the whole idea is the end of season one
is meant to be the greens basically stealing the
Iron Throne from rhaenyra wouldn't be a big payoff
at the end of season two if Rainer steals it back
from them and they really really want you to see
the parallels between Rainier and Daenerys like
they look the same already they have the same hair
braids they even use daenerys's music when she was
flying in on Cyrax at the beginning of season
one both of them are Rebels and they both quoted
the phrase that they would upend the old ways and
start their new order saying I will create a new
order here's the other side of that coin though
both rhaenyra and Daenerys said neither one wanted
to be Queen of the ashes when dragons go to war
everything burns but look at what happened with
Daenerys so much collateral damage the maesters
the small folk all thought her a tyrant after the
fact the mazers even recorded that Daenerys went
mad like her father the Mad King during House of
the Dragon much earlier in the timeline the realm
had just experienced makeover the cruel's Reign
before King jaehaerys in fact they reference
makeover the cruel at the beginning of episode
1 so that will be the metaphor that rhaenyra wants
to avoid like everyone the small folk thinking her
the next coming of maegor the cruel so the big
question is whether or not the realm is going
to remember renura fondly or think of her as the
next Maegor the cruel because it seems like she
wants to burn them all now I know there's a lot
of other questions about characters like amid
what is he going to do next when he comes back to
King's Landing is he gonna tell alicent oh I just
wound up killing my nephew on accident I think I
started the actual Targaryen Civil War the dance
of the Dragons oops my bad I do have a bunch
of separate bonus videos planned for other big
characters so I'll talk more about aemond during
that video and the other characters during those
so if you have any big questions or things I
didn't address in this video just write them
below in the comments and I'll try to add them
to those bonus videos everyone click here for my
full House of the Dragon episode 10 finale video
and click here for all my other house the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!